ce que vous haïssez dans la chanson
le côté
focus on va dire
bonsoir bonsoir Thierry alors je sais
pas si vous avez entendu depuis votre
loge dans les coulisses mais Laurent
Gerra est d'accord entre Anne Sinclair
l'ordre Sinclair et Bob Sinclair c'est
avec vous qu'il est prêt à partir trois
ans dans un vaisseau spatial
il y a un entraînement nécessaire avant
tout vol habité donc effectivement
oui parce que toutes ces fiancés les a
rencontrés sur des plateaux de télé
comme beaucoup d'ex stars du porno vous
cherchez à vous reconvertir et vous vous
avez choisi la chanson exactement déjà
vous aviez sorti une chanson à la
rentrée 2000 qui était une reprise de
porque te vas de Jeannette c'est pas
trop marché
j'ai eu beaucoup de médias qui m'ont
suivi la télé et en même temps aussi les
magazines quoi aujourd'hui il y a une
autre une autre chanson qui est une
reprise de trous de Spandau ballet vous
savez comment on fait
pour la gonzesse avec qui tu vas passer
trois ans le vaisseau
bien alors ça s'appelle vous en français
c'est pas votre truc ça c'est pas votre
kiffe je panneau ballet
est-ce que ça peut changer votre image
ce disque ben oui oui je suis en train
de changer mon image non c'est vrai
quand je vous vois là je pense plus du
tout à tous ces films
donc maintenant vous allez aimer ma
chanson
vous cherchez un petit peu quand même à
vous racheter une conduite non on a
l'impression non pas du tout je reste
surtout moi-même et j'avais envie de
chanter depuis très longtemps donc
producteur par exemple il envoie quand
même des lettres de menaces judiciaires
à tous les sites X qui vous mentionnent
encore pour qu'il ne parle plus de vous
c'est logique quand même non vous dites
que vous assumez il faut assumer le
passé le présent et l'avenir
je pense que j'ai exercé pendant 18 mois
j'ai montré aux gens ce que j'ai fait
dans ce métier j'ai exercé un métier et
puis maintenant je passe à autre chose
donc je pense que j'ai le droit d'avoir
ma chance
je sais pas que j'en veux c'est pas que
je ne veux plus mais
alors par exemple
une différence sensible entre vos
interviews de l'époque et vos interviews
maintenant
ça vous dites plus la même chose sur
votre passé je comparer là haute vidéo
et jolie
sur votre premier tournage par exemple
pendant autre vidéo vous dites
j'étais très intimidé mais très vite
j'étais mise en confiance avec mon
premier partenaire Christophe Clark donc
là il y a pas de problème c'était à
l'époque et aujourd'hui dans jeune et
jolie vous dites je me sentais humilié
je me sentais sale je me l'avais sans
arrêt
dans un domaine on montre toujours le
côté positif et lorsqu'on ouvre les yeux
et qu'on se rend compte de ce qu'on a
fait et bien on pense plus la même chose
autre exemple par exemple sur vos
parents dans je n'ai je lis vous dites
j'ai eu aucun contact familial pendant
plus de deux ans quand j'appelais mes
parents ils me raccrochait au nez puis
alors après dans un autre journal vous
dites mes parents n'ont jamais cessé de
me soutenir j'ai eu une rupture je pense
que c'est une chose logique et ensuite
je leur ai expliqué et ils m'ont
peut-être compris et peut-être même
pardonner faudrait leur demander mais
pour l'instant le contact est revenu et
ça se passe très bien
[Applaudissements]
c'est la façon dont vous êtes rentrés
dans ce monde du cinéma X en 95 à Rennes
au salon érotique curiosa 95
vous voyez des
pornostars disons qui dansent et vous
dites je veux c'est mon truc je veux en
faire partie c'est ma vie c'est mon
choix c'est moi
avec des amis à ce salon parce que c'est
le premier à Rennes évidemment je pense
qu'on est curieux et curieuse donc nous
sommes allés à salon et de là j'ai vu
des jeunes filles danser oui ça c'est
vrai et on va danser un défi de capable
de monter sur scène et comme je pensais
que c'était que des professionnels qui
montaient sur scène donc j'ai dit je
suis capable et ben arrivé devant de
faire accompli ben malheureusement la
personne a dit mais il y a pas de
problème vous pouvez monter ah et donc
je suis quand même montée
[Rires]
le contrat a commencé telle date
finissait-elle date et j'ai arrêté
dans certaines interviews vous dites que
vous avez été forcés vous parlez
traquenard de gens sans scrupules de
système par jour sans me laisser
souffler vous avez souffert vraiment
alors un petit peu moralement
physiquement
quand on est honnête
vécu même si maintenant je regrette de
l'avoir fait ou si elles font autre
chose et des filles qui sont venus ici
qui sont
qui n'ont pas souffert à ce point-là
non c'est difficile
si je devais refaire ma vie non
un vrai cauchemar on peut dire ça comme
ça oui quel bilan en fait de votre vie
jusqu'à maintenant
et bien
le hic c'était une et mon passé
maintenant le futur c'est la chanson
comme vous avez eu des hauts et des bas
on va faire une interview upenda c'est
normal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans commande
ce que vous préférez en vous
moi aussi parce que je préfère en moi
c'est ma gentil
on est pareil finalement ce que vous
détestez en vous
ma gourmandise
j'ai de la chance
le texte parce que je l'ai choisi en
général je lis tous les textes qu'on
m'apporte j'ai un auteur qui s'appelle
franchie qui écrit toujours mes textes
et quand je suis pas d'accord et ben
poubelle et on recommence
ce que vous haïssez dans la chanson
le côté
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup elle m'aide elle est
gentille c'est vrai ce que vous préférez
dans le porno
c'est la première fois que je vois un
tel rejet
c'est vous
ce que vous supportiez pas dans le porno
la maltraitance
[Musique]
on est considéré comme des cliniques on
nous utilise on nous jette
le film de vous vous préférez
le film
porno
celui que vous trouvez le moins bien
mais honnêtement je me trouve vraiment
très moche dans les films
[Musique]
il faut que je me fasse une idée là on
peut pas se quitter comme ça
le plus grand moment de votre vie
le démarrage dans la chanson je pense
c'est une nouvelle vie pour moi
et le pire moment de votre vie
à part maintenant quoi
le pire moment je pense que c'est Maman
qui ont été très difficiles lorsque j'ai
arrêté pendant un an là j'ai énormément
souffert normalement et physiquement
donc je pense que ça va être le pire
moment de ma vie ça vous avez trouvé de
réconfort comment à cette époque là
votre plus gros coup de fric
au loto
j'ai gagné loto
non j'ai gagné une petite somme donc
c'était marrant
l'Hippopotamus tous les deux si vous
voulez
votre plus grosse perte de fric
mon avocat
j'en ai une quand j'étais jeune à 18 ans
j'ai eu quelqu'un que j'ai aimé très
fort pendant deux mois
j'ai eu quelqu'un que j'ai mis pendant
deux mois très très fort et
malheureusement il est parti donc
voilà j'ai pas eu de chance sur ce
coup-là donc à 18 ans c'est très très
difficile accepter quoi
[Applaudissements]
votre plus moche histoire d'amour
ce soir avec vous
[Rires]
parce que vous avez de plus sexy en vous
je pense que les hommes penseront autre
chose mais moi je pense que j'ai un beau
regard je suis sexy
ce que vous avez de moins sexy en vous
mes jambes je suis petite et
j'aimerais être plus grande
le plus dans le sexe
la tendresse et la douceur qu'est-ce qui
vous dégoûte
la violence c'est la brutalité quoi
j'aime pas ça vous êtes prêtes pour
devenir un peu lesbienne quand même non
pas du tout non quand on dit ça
viendra un jour
j'aurais peur de recevoir
des emails pour vous donc dites ce que
vous cherchez c'est rappeler ça nous
permettra de les trier non mais j'ai pas
spécialement de type je pense que c'est
le courant passe et que ça soit un homme
sincère
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu